good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
one sunday afternoon last september a 16
year old boy called aaron pryor was shot
to death in a driveway near his home in
oakland california
even by the standards of midday drive-by
shootings it was an awful crime
surveillance footage showed the killer
firing more than a dozen rounds before
fleeing
no one was arrested for their murder but
local media did not seem especially
interested in finding out who did it
because they already knew the
coronavirus
killed aaron pryor that's what they told
us one local television station noted
that violence in the area had risen
since the pandemic began
they must be connected pryor's football
coach agreed with this
it was kovid that really killed this kid
he told reporters
the coach didn't explain how exactly
covett had done this killing or what
kobut's motive might have been
but no one asked everyone particularly
people in power
seemed happy to blame kovit the pandemic
did it
you heard that a lot and not just in
california
across the country in new york city
mayor bill de blasio blamed blind
rising crime rates squarely on the virus
police organizations will say that part
of the reason that crime is up is
because there has been a cut in funding
to the nypd
what do you say to that this predates
any funding decisions that's just the
truth the perfect storm i mentioned
started in march and april when
everything's shut down
and we saw the violence start in earnest
may into june
uh into july and it's clearly because
things came unglued
it must have been the pandemic that
makes sense the quarantine did it we
forced everyone to stay home
and that's why there's so many people on
the streets shooting each other and
pushing strangers into oncoming subway
cars
does that make sense do you know it
doesn't make sense to anyone
but thankfully experts soon emerged to
explain why something so obviously
untrue must in fact be true quote
because of the stresses of the pandemic
they're everywhere explaining a former
cia officer called jeff
asher to the new york times you are
seeing this
everywhere except we're not seeing this
everywhere that's not true the
coronavirus may be global but rising
crime rates are not global
police in canada for example reported
that crime fell by 18
between march and october of last year
in the uk
crime saw its biggest annual decrease in
a decade
in sweden and russia crime dropped too
even in mexico
which is the middle of a drug war there
were fewer homicides in 2020 than there
were in 2019.
so for normal countries pretty much all
countries the pandemic meant
more netflix but less killing
not here in the united states the
opposite happened
a lot of netflix even more killings
you're seeing the data on your screen
right now it's from a non-profit called
the council on criminal justice
and researchers at the university of
missouri it shows the average weekly
homicide rate in 21 major cities
killings spiked in late may well after
the pandemic began
according to council on criminal justice
quote homicides aggravated assaults
gun assaults rose significantly
beginning in late may and june of 2020
they jumped by 40 percent during the
summer and 34
in the fall when compared to the
previous summer and fall
so far this year these sad trends have
continued murders are up
800 percent in portland oregon they're
up 56 percent in minneapolis
seen of george floyd's death they're up
27 in la 22 in new york
they're up 40 percent in philadelphia
so you have to ask yourself because your
life may depend on it
why is this country different from say
sweden or russia
or mexico and you know the answer
it's not covid it's that in our country
stupid malicious people took full
control the democratic party took full
control
of the country and their policies
resulted in a huge number of killings
that's not speculation they've bragged
about it here they are bragging about
their plans
the folks in law enforcement that share
the goals
of reimagining policing imagining
policing
in the 21st century rethinking and
reimagining policing
community efforts to reimagine policing
to reimagine
policing we have to reimagine what
policing looks like reimagining policing
reimagining our public safety
reimagine a citizen-led approach and
begin to reimagine
law enforcement reimagine public safety
in this country
what can we do to reimagine public
safety reimagining public safety to
reimagine public safety
we must reimagine what public safety
looks like
well they definitely reimagined public
safety they made the public
much less safe according to a report in
axios 20 major u.s cities have slashed
their police budgets in the last year
they defunded the police collectively
they cut more than 840 million dollars
from law enforcement
in atlanta in a story that we love to
read one city councilman who voted to
strip 73 million from the police a
genius called antonio brown
just had his car stolen in broad
daylight by children
who were not held back by the police
they'd been defunded
must have been covid that did it
meanwhile at least 25 cities have pulled
police out of public schools they've
canceled the contracts
how's that going to work you know the
answer at universities activists have
pushed for the same
total abolition of the police when they
said we're going to defund the police
they meant it at the university of
chicago dozens of students swarmed the
home
of the college president one of them an
especially entitled young lady called
madeleine wright
shouted this through a megaphone quote
we're going to fight to abolish this
effing system
not reform it professors at the school
joined her one of them a character
called damon
jones led seminars on the problem of
over policing in the neighborhood around
the university of chicago it's called
hyde park
it's where obama's from the professor
wrote dozens of posts on twitter last
summer explaining that because the
university of chicago's police
stop more african americans than white
people in a predominantly black
neighborhood keep in mind
they're racist what's interesting is
that damon jones hasn't said anything on
twitter about the police
since january of this year why january
well that's when yerin fawn a
thirty-year-old phd student at the
university of chicago
was murdered in a killing spree on
chicago's south side along with two
other people
killed for being there and at that point
it's possible that even morons like
damon jones realized there's a reason
the university of chicago has one of the
largest private police
forces outside the vatican why because
the neighborhood around the school
is a very dangerous place that's not the
fault of the police
that's the reason they have police and
that could be true for the entire city
of chicago
which is dangerous and becoming more so
by the day
now why has that happened it's happened
because people with a political agenda
have taken over law enforcement it was
in chicago for example that blm
activists declared that looting stealing
is a form of reparations watch
they get upset when people start looting
people in this city are struggling
through a pandemic
so i don't care if somebody decides to
loot a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations
so you got to steal from gucci to eat
stealing
is reparations now that's insane and
only a very sick society would listen to
someone like that
someone like that would be dismissed
automatically in a healthy society
but in this case not a single democratic
politician pushed back
so guess what happened well in the city
of san francisco for example walgreens
has closed 17 different stores why
because prosecutors in san francisco and
in many other places throughout the
state of california for example
but not just there no longer charge
shoplifters
so people steal whatever they want there
is so much theft on such a scale that
the stores cannot afford to stay open
they're not closing as a political
statement they're closing because
they can't afford to have their
merchandise stolen
this is not the country you were born in
here's what it looks like
the walgreens at vanessa and eddie in
san francisco will close its doors for
good november 11th
customers say the store is known for
being a notoriously easy place to
shoplift
i've heard the walgreens is really easy
to peel from because they don't chase
you
and neighbors agree shoplifting has been
an ongoing problem at this location
and may be a major factor in why it will
soon be closed
customers say the shelves are bare the
company not even bothering to restock
so to be clear it's not that americans
have become more prone
to steal it's that stealing is now
allowed
and when you allow something you get
more of it
so this is the result of intentional
policies designed to give us more
stealing
designed to give us more murder more
rate more pushing strangers in front of
subway cars it's happened
because the people in charge allowed it
to happen
and it's happening everywhere it's
particularly happening in new york
several candidates for mayor of new york
people running to replace bill de blasio
have announced that anyone who opposes
stealing is quote criminalizing
poverty who are the people of views like
that they're not normal people they are
it goes the
saying pampered out of touch liberals
they're the only ones who can afford
views like that
actress cynthia nixon certainly fits
that description
nixon expressed outrage the other day
that the cvs in her neighborhood
was trying to prevent thieves from
walking off with their entire inventory
quote i can't imagine thinking that the
way to solve the problem of people
stealing
basic necessities out of desperation is
to prosecute them
so you've got to wonder what would
happen if you showed up at cynthia
nixon's place tonight and tried to help
yourself to some quote basic necessities
would cynthia nixon understand your
theft as a profound form of social
protest
as a form of social justice would she
applaud it
or would she tell her bodyguards to
shoot you and then thank them profusely
when they did
it's not a tough question you'd be dead
in seconds
cynthia nixon doesn't mean a word of
what she says about crime
none of them mean a word of what they
say about crime
they're just trying to feel like good
people in a world that confuses
destruction for virtue
these people need help they should be
nowhere near power
unfortunately at the moment they run the
democratic party
and all of us are seeing the results of
that hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else